parlez donc deux avec vous ives denis
d'amitié et solidarité
pour ces familles en difficulté c'est
une association que vous avez fondé à la
fin du mois d'août déjà tout simplement
pourquoi vous êtes lancés dans ce
dispositif amitié et solidarité
bon c'est officiellement paru au journal
officiel fin du mois d'août commencer
les activités
on a commencé d'activité il ya un peu
plus un peu plus de trois mois
lorsque j'ai fermé l'antenne d'une
association nationale qui était dans mon
domicile
donc cette association était fermé et on
était un groupe d'anciens à avoir créé
cette nouvelle association avec les
mêmes orientations
c'est à dire l'accès à la culture et à
l'éducation en milieu de difficultés de
vie comme dante les gens des problèmes
la culture c'est pas la priorité est
donc l'idée c'est de dire on ya des
associations qui donnent à manger des
associations qui permettent d'aller au
théâtre pas cher ou qui permettent aux
enfants de faire une activité comme on
fait car on a partenariat avec la
médiathèque avec la bnf est le château
de versailles
on a un partenariat avec un mécène qui
nous a déjà financé 40 baptême de l'air
là la semaine dernière on vient de faire
30 sorties aux grandes eaux nocturnes du
château de versailles
bon c'est une sortie qui vaut 23 euros
normalement les personnes ont payé 5
euros et les familles qui sont en
difficulté ont payé 2 euros parce que
voilà c'était juste pour dire que ont
fait pas d'opération gratuite on en a
jamais fait ça qui vous connaissent sur
saint quentin en yvelines parce que vous
nous l'avez dit vous
cogner l'antenne d'une autre association
quel secours populaire c'est remonter à
1992 vous à votre engagement dans le
secours populaire et 2004 la création de
l'antenne sur guyancourt et pourquoi
l'avoir fermé cette antenne brièvement
qu'est ce qui s'est passé pourquoi avoir
continué les activités avec une nouvelle
association on expliquer peut-être aux
saint quentinois qui peuvent se demander
pourquoi ça change le nom même si dans
le fond les missions sont les mêmes en
fait oui c'est même si ces mêmes
personnes c'est à dire qu'en fait ce
qu'on veut plaire c'est une très grande
association ainsi une belle association
n'y a pas de souci là-dessus qu'ils
aient beaucoup d'action sur l'aide
alimentaire le vestiaire et puis aussi
un petit peu d'elle administrative moi
quand j'ai créé l'antenne c'était pour
faire trois activités parents qui était
une journée à la mer une journée à noël
et une journée au parc astérix qui se
faisait à l'époque et je me suis
retrouvé seul dans mon dans mon style
et puis comme dans mon style je suis
aussi un peu bizarre au lieu de faire
trois activités parents en huit ans j'en
ai fait la fermeture on en était à 196
donc ce n'était pas tout à fait le même
rythme et du coup c'est pas tout à fait
dans l'esprit sur oculaire et puis je
sois oculaire préside li na fédération
c'est quand même principalement des
salariés
et moi je suis quand même bénévole
depuis la première création depuis ma
première présidence en 1968
d'associations et j'ai un peu l'habitude
des associations et je considère que ce
sont les bénévoles qui doivent employer
des salariés et par l'averse amitié et
solidarité dont on a ou d'un moment on
arrêtait et sabre aussi bien la
différence maintenant pour nous c'est
que avant je téléphonais parents un
quart difficile et là qu'il faut on
vient d'emmener 63 personnes une journée
à la mer à olga tu es là il faut se
trouve 1100 euros pour payer le car
comment vous fonctionnez justement
maintenant qu'il n'ya plus on va dire la
cuy en tout cas l'image d'une grande
association pour vous aider voilà il ya
plus de l'appui d'une grande association
enfin on a quand même un réseau d argent
quand même 300 familles d'inscrits g700
enfants d'inscrits j'ai quand même
beaucoup de
anky qui me connaissent parce que bon je
fais le secours populaire mais j'étais
encore président du club de plongée de
nos repas j'ai créé une dizaine
d'associations spiritisme 968 s'entendre
vous participez à des associations
voilà donc que je connais jean et là on
a obtenu par des dons de particuliers
et puis de deux entreprises voisines de
chez moi dans le village de bruit en
cours des dons qui ont permis de payer
le quart et puis il se trouve que la
communauté d'agglo a trouvé que le
projet était intéressant puisque on
faisait une sortie pour les familles le
29 août
c'est à dire qu'à ce moment là les gens
qui n'ont pas été en vacances iront plus
les enfants qui ont rien à raconter
n'auront rien à raconter et du coup la
communauté d'agglomération a appris une
décision extrêmement rapidement en une
semaine de nous aider au financement de
l'autocar pour emmener les familles il
journée à la mer et on s'est retrouvé
avec des mamans qui avaient jamais vu la
mère des enfants qui avaient jamais vu
la mer on a si on a une seconde juste
une petite anecdote c'est qu'à un moment
et à monsieur qui est arrivé il avait
été se promener quand il est revenu il a
vu la mer il s'est précipité on a une
maîtrise helliwell amer pour le 10 mai
s'est marré parce que c'est vrai qu'il
ya kilomètres d'och la presse conseille
pas cet ex monsieur était sri lankais et
qu'en 2004 avec un tsunami qui l'avait
vu et donc c'était beaucoup moins drôle
que ce qu'on croyait mais sur le moment
on a trouvé cette lan voilà donc c'est
quand même des gens qui vont jamais en
vacances c'est parti toutes les
activités que vous menez ont mené
régulièrement on peut vous aider il ya
un blog ou un site internet qui était
mis en place la drees va s'afficher à
micher solidarité pour un blogspot point
fr vos prochains projets peut-être alors
le prochain le projet on a
un partenariat avec la médiathèque de
guyancourt et le château de versailles
qu'on va réactiver
j'ai encore un accord de principe il
faut qu'on arrête une date pour les
vacances de toussaint donc en général on
fait une sortie au château de versailles
là aux vacances de toussaint et dans la
semaine précédente on va à la
médiathèque les enfants sont formés on
les ponts alors dit il faut antique 1 et
voyages et après on va
et puis là actuellement je suis en train
de chercher un financement pour
financement et un projet pour avoir une
sortie de noël pour les familles pouvoir
emmener le petit ballon d'un homme
car si on a les moyens deux autocars
parce qu'on sait qu'on va aller remplir
au cirque au spectacle et éventuellement
à tarifer visite style parce qu on est
quand même dans les loisirs et la
culture
donc ça nous est arrivé de faire une
sortie par exemple à la cité des
sciences
et puis l'après-midi de faire une sortie
sur une heure de avec les vedettes sur
la scène voilà donc ça fait une journée
qui est quand même qu'on complète depuis
1968 à travers différentes associations
vous connaissez la réalité du terrain
tout à l'heure sur ce plateau on parlait
du logement du mal logement ont dit la
france victimes du mal-logement de la
précarité c'est un sujet d'actualité
nationale ont pas forcément
départementale ni même sur saint quentin
en yvelines mais vous qui voyez la
réalité son terrain peut-être pour
conclure cet entretien dites nous
comment vous ressentez les choses que la
précarité les difficultés à se loger
sont de plus en plus grande
le public que vous recevez en souffre
forcément alors rapidement pour port
situé vous prenez ce que ce qui rentre
dans une famille un les ailes et le
salaire éventuel les choses comme ça
d'un côté l'autre côté vous mettez les
assurances de téléphone
les incompressibles vous faites la
différence vous / 30 jours par le nombre
de femmes de personnes de la famille et
ça vous donne un reste à vivre
il va rester de l'olive à rester à sa
vie à se nourrir
moi j'ai déjà innové une maman ils sont
trois il lui manque trois euros 60 par
personne par jour
bon allez c'est pas la seule et voilà et
on a beaucoup de gens qui ont moins de 5
euros par personne
pour vivre donc c'est extrêmement
compliqué et actuellement les personnes
qui cherchent un logement s'ils passent
pas par le 115 en étant la rue ils en
trouvent pas qu'en ce moment on en est
là donc est actuellement moi j'ai dix
sept personnes en domiciliation postale
donc c'est des gens qui peuvent être à
l'hôtel saint-yves à versailles qui
peuvent être au foyer sonacotra qui
s'appelle prisoner traduit en cours qui
peuvent habiter chez des copains mais
qui ne peuvent pas avoir d' adresse et
sans une adresse postale
ils peuvent pas avoir de banques qui
peuvent faire aucune démarche ils
peuvent pas aller à la mairie de
montigny demander une aide
il en faut une adresse donc moi j'ai dit
cette personne et puis c'est vrai ça
bouge tous les jours justement vous êtes
tourné vers isabelle ramin je vous
posais la question parce que les
services de la ville de
montigny-le-bretonneux aujourd'hui ont
beaucoup de demandes est ce que vous
constatez en tant qu'élu ça fait partie
des dossiers que la mairie doit gérer
bien sûr alors à montigny c'est vrai que
par exemple nous avons non pas sur le
champ de la culture où nous faisons
quand même beaucoup de choses mais par
exemple la boutique alimentaire qui
fonctionne 365 jours par jour par an
donc c'est énorme parce que pas un jour
une famille dans le besoin n'est pas
aidé alimentairement avec soit une
légère participation voire pas de
participation du tout donc c'est vrai
que le ccas à montigny le centre
communal d'action sociale a vraiment
aide beaucoup beaucoup de familles qui
sans ces aides c'est vrai aurait encore
beaucoup plus de difficultés merci la
belle rama
vous étiez sur ce plateau nous parler
une jeunesse du dispositif sos rentrée
merci à y gagner
donc bon temps avec vous pour vous avec
cette association amitié et solidarité
donc poursuivez vos activités
du côté de guyancourt avant de conclure
cette édition voici un rappel des
principaux sujets de l'actualité locale
de ce 10 septembre la situation du
logement à saint quentin en yvelines
cécile duflot ministre du logement a
fait des propositions pour débloquer des
terrains appartenant à l'état plusieurs
de ces terrains se trouve d'ailleurs
elle dans l'agglomération de saint
quentin en yvelines les élus
s'interrogent ont trouvé le sujet
complet dans l'actu 20h30 sur notre
antenne
une rentrée particulière ce lundi à lune
cité de versailles-saint-quentin celle
des étudiants étrangers la volonté pour
l'université de versailles-saint-quentin
ouvrir de plus en plus ses portes aux
étudiants venus d'ailleurs une façon
d'étendre sa popularité au delà des
frontières
le club de vélo de montigny le
bretonneux mais le plus important club
d'île de france avec 400 licenciés il
organisait sa fête du vélo ce week end
idéal pour remobiliser les troupes et
puis toujours à montigny du football
féminin lé dinh l'antenne évolue en
deuxième division défaite à domicile
face à templemars vendeville un promu
pour cette reprise deux saisons
n'oubliez pas aussi que vous pouvez
retrouver tous nos sujets sur notre site
internet ainsi que tous les extraits de
cette émission du 7-8 le gouvernement au
chevet du logement social avant un
projet de loi avant qu'ils ne soient
présentés prochainement nous avons voulu
faire le point sur le secteur de saint
quentin en yvelines sur ce logement
social on écoute maxime lemaire pour
atteindre l'objectif de 150 mille
nouveaux logements sociaux par an fixé
par françois hollande pendant sa
campagne la ministre cécile duflot a
proposé la semaine dernière un
renforcement de la loi sru
la loi de solidarité et de
renouvellement urbain jusqu'à présent en
ile-de-france les communes de plus de
1500 habitants devait avoir en moins 20%
de logements sociaux
la ministre souhaite voir ce chiffre
augmenter de 5 points
où en sont les communes sur le
territoire de saint quentin en yvelines
petit tour d'horizon en chiffres la
verrière arrive en tête des sept
communes suivie de près par trappe et
magny les hameaux manyu deux projets
immobiliers comportant des logements
sociaux sont prévus à l'est des
capucines et rue gabriel-péri guyancourt
se place en quatrième position
230 nouveaux logements sociaux devraient
sortir de terre prochainement à villeroy
sud au niveau de la ferme de châteauneuf
et sur l'emplacement de l'ancienne école
paul langevin ils seront mélangés avec
des habitats classique afin de favoriser
la mixité sociale
la commune de guyancourt a d'ailleurs
indiqué dans son pays et lui que tout
projet de construction de 60 logements
ou plus doit comporter 50 % de logements
sociaux et l'encours et montigny le
bretonneux sont au coude à coude voisins
le bretonneux quant à elle arrive bonne
dernière c'est la seule commune à ne pas
respecter les 20% de logements sociaux
obligatoires
les sanctions encourues jusqu'à l'or
pourrait être multiplié par 5 avec la
nouvelle loi qui sera étudié à
l'assemblée nationale à partir du 24
septembre
cette émission sera rediffusée à 19h
22h30 minuit réalisation ce soir romain
brusc fini on se retrouve pour un
prochain en direct du 7 8 à 18 heures
mardi au programme le goncourt des
lycéens auxquels participent à l'iss et
de plaisir ou encore un retour sur les
inquiétudes des buralistes
ils étaient mobilisés je vous le
rappelle en fin de semaine dernière
contre le plan anti tabac a voulue par
l'europe voulue par bruxelles et puis
nous ferons bien sûr le point sur toute
l'actualité locale rendez vous demain
mardi en direct à 18h excellente soirée